[Music]
hi everybody
um my name is ganesh taylor as has been
mentioned and we are here today to talk
about lost in the matrix
until recently
the possibility that we're living in a
computer simulation was largely limited
to fans of the matrix bit like myself
but some scientists and philosophers are
taking seriously
the claim that strange quirks of the
universe and the black hole information
paradox are evidence that our reality is
actually a created simulation
even elon musk has come out supporting
the theory arguing that we are most
likely in a simulation
is the idea that we are living in a
computer simulation a real possibility
or is this a sign that we can all be
victims to a hollywood fantasy
then again
is this simply a new version of the
philosophical question made famous by
descartes can we be sure that reality is
not a dream
and if so why is it so persistent
so to our speakers
um on my left anders sandberg is a
researcher a popular science debater and
a transhumanist he holds a phd in
computational neuroscience from the
university of stockholm
sabine hosenfelder to my far right is a
theoretical physicist who is uh also
author of lost in math how beauty leads
physics astray
anil seth just immediately to my right
here is a professor of cognitive and
computational neuroscientists
neuroscience excuse me he is a
co-director of the sackler center for
consciousness science and
editor-in-chief of neuroscience in
consciousness
uh and uh to my far left is massimo
piluci a philosopher a philosophy
professor at the city college of new
york and former co-host of the
rationally speaking podcast what an
illustrious panel
so with no further ado and what happens
now is i'm going to throw out a question
and each of you get three minutes and
three minutes alone to answer the
question the question is the following
is the idea that we are living in a
computer simulation a real possibility
anders europe
okay
i started out as a computation
neuroscientist and then i ended up in
the philosophy department in oxford at
the future humanity institute
and my boss nick bostrom wrote the paper
about the simulation argument so just
quickly outline it he argues that if we
survive and get our act together as a
species we're going to develop in an
advanced post-human civilization with
enormous computing power and at least
some of that is going to be used to run
simulations of the past because of
entertainment historical dramas or
figuring out what really happened in
those important years in the early 21st
century
and of course that's going to be a lot
of simulations so hence it seems like if
you're a mind in the early 21st century
you might actually more likely be one of
the simulated minds rather than one of
the few minds that exist in the real
world
so his paper ends up with a trilemma we
have to believe in at least one really
annoying or crazy thing either that we
will never reach this post-human state
that we will go extinct because of some
global disaster
or that post humans never do this
simulation may either because it's
impossible to actually do
or because we're all deciding oh that
would be totally unethical subjecting
people to the world of 2021 no that's
not ethical not even to simulated people
or the third possibility we're actually
happily simulated
he doesn't give a probability really
maybe you can say that it's one given
equal chances
but we really don't have any way of
telling do i believe that we're
simulated as we will probably get to i
think that it doesn't matter
but the trilemma is important it's
important that we might actually have to
think that our world is much weirder
than we normally think makes sense
fascinating sabine what do you think
so i'm a theoretical physicist and i
spend my day-to-day life trying to
figure out how the fundamental laws of
nature work and
whenever i hear about the computer
simulation you get a little bit offended
so that you get all these philosopher
types who make big statements about how
the laws of nature work but never seem
to actually bother to look at
how they actually do work
so when it comes to the question do we
have on a computer simulation there's
the obvious thing to say it all depends
on what you mean by computer simulation
if you just mean
does the universe in some way calculate
the laws of nature
i think and i guess most physicists
would agree with me the answer is yes
because all our fundamental theories are
mathematical in nature and that's really
the only thing that this statement says
but normally what people have in mind
when they talk about the
simulation hypothesis
is that it's actually some kind of
computer that works pretty much the same
way that our current computers work that
calculate the laws on a step-by-step
basis
and
of course the important question is who
programmed it so that's always the the
big uh overarching question and now if
you look at the question like could it
be that the universe
is created
by a program running on a computer
of the type that we know
the answer is no
because the fundamental laws of nature
that we have so far are not of that
algorithmic type that proceeds step by
step
and this causes a problem
because
strictly speaking if you're trying to
make predictions for what people should
see in such a simulation it just doesn't
agree with what we actually observe and
there are some people have looked for it
there should be subtle violations of
certain symmetries for example and it's
just incompatible with observations very
clear thank you very much i mean i know
where where are you going to take this
well i don't like the simulation
argument but that's not in itself a good
reason to dismiss it
although it's pretty good
the reasons i dismiss it firstly i think
to this question you know what's what's
the question we started with it's um is
there a real possibility that we are i
think this is a with apologies to the
organizers a slightly badly put question
it's very difficult to exclude
everything completely for me it's like
what credence should we assign that kind
of uh that possibility and i think it's
very low i think the simulation argument
and has beautifully summarized is really
weak in a couple of ways firstly it asks
us to assign
probabilities to things that we have
really no idea how to assign
probabilities to what would our far
distant ancestors feel like doing with
with some extrapolation of the kinds of
technology that we have today to
sabine's point people have an idea of
what a computer simulation tends to mean
probably motivated by a desire that we
might if this is true we could upload
ourselves into the cloud and live
forever uh so we're asked to assign
probabilities or we don't have a good
idea what those probabilities should be
more importantly it's not just a
trilemma it's a i think it's a
quadrilema i'm not even sure if that is
a word
that is a another fundamental assumption
in all these ideas that is glossed over
and this is the idea that consciousness
is substrate independent as as boston
himself puts it in his in his lovely
paper that it doesn't matter whether
brains are made of carbon or silicon
that conscious that if you run the right
program on a computer of some kind
consciousness will happen he says this
is widely accepted in philosophy of mind
and in neuroscience it is somewhat
accepted but that's also not by everyone
and it's not obvious at all that this is
the case there are some things which if
you simulate them
you bring them about a computer playing
chess actually is playing chess there
are other things that if you simulate
them
you you just simulate them you don't
actually instantiate them if you have a
simulation of a weather system it
doesn't actually get wet it's a
simulation of a weather system so where
does consciousness lie on the spectrum i
don't actually know but i'm very
suspicious of assuming that it is
something that we can stimulate and i'll
finish because there's a positive reason
to be suspicious of that right we are
biological creatures we're made of
neurons neurons are made of other things
the other things are made of other
things and so on and so on all the way
down
where does the substrate start and the
other stuff stop where does the mind
wear start
and the wet wear stop
where is this substrate that
consciousness is supposed to be
independent of in a real computer we
know because that's how they're designed
they're designed so that you can run
anything on the hardware biological
systems are not like that
they're bootstrapped by living processes
all the way down so i'm suspicious of
the idea that consciousness is substrate
independent doesn't mean it isn't it
just means i wouldn't want to rest a
massive claim about the nature of the
universe on something so uncertain as
that
interesting okay well massimo
your thoughts i'm beginning to think
that this panel is unbalanced
which i'm fine with because i'm on the
majority side so
despite being a philosopher although my
background actually originates in
science i do agree with sabine
and the point that she has made i also
agree with anal
as a biologist in particular i think
that consciousness is very likely the
result of a process of organic
biological evolution and just like any
other
process of biological evolution it does
require substrates that doesn't mean
that only one particular substrate would
do i i
will not make a claim that unless it's
made of carbon phosphorus and so on and
so forth it cannot be conscious but i
will make the comp the comment that the
substrate does matter we can simulate
all sorts of other biological processes
one of the famous uh examples is
photosynthesis we can
simulate photosynthesis down to the
quantum level
we really know a lot about
photosynthesis but you know one thing
you don't get out of simulated
photosynthesis is sugar which is the
only thing that actually matters about
photosynthesis so is as anal said is is
consciousness in in the same realm as
photosynthesis or not i think that is an
open question but my bet as a biologist
is that yes it is it's it's somewhere in
that in that area
the other issue i think that it's
interesting to bring up here is
the way the the this first question is
phrased which is exactly
how
is it possible
is the idea that we are living in a
computer simulation a real possibility
right what do you mean by real
possibility as opposed to a fake
possibility
um and also what do we
what do we mean by possibility so i
imagine that uh
all sorts of things are possible not
everything is possible by the way we
know certain things are impossible right
something violates the laws of physics
it is physically impossible if something
violates logic it is logically
impossible so not everything is possible
a lot of these arguments about the
matrix and similar are actually based
not even on possibility however they're
pla they're based on something called
conceivability
it is conceivable that you know but
considerability is not a parameter that
you can actually trust
um it just means that you are thinking
about something and you think oh
wouldn't it be cool that if if the world
worked that way
we have a long history of things that
appeared that were conceivable and yet
were later on demonstrated to be either
physically or logically impossible
squaring the circle was supposed to be
conceivable for centuries for many
centuries until somebody actually showed
mathematically this is not possible you
just can't do it so considerability is
really not a good guide toward what we
should be interested or not probability
is so if we could get some kind of
reasonable estimate of probability uh
then it would be on a different track
but again i agree with anna i don't
think we can i don't think we have any
any particular good reason we can make
up stuff you can say well based on
subjective bayesian probability blah
blah blah i think the probability of the
matrix is 30
it i'm just making that up there's
there's no reason to go one way or the
other so uh
that is that is an important distinction
to keep in mind between conceivability
which is no guidance at all
possibility which is a very vague
concept sure all sorts of things are
possible but should we be interested in
those uh the answer is well we should if
they're probable but in this case i
don't think that okay well i want a
disclaimer the fact that i didn't write
that question to begin with this section
but let's just move on to to our next
question in that case so do we think
that it is actually reasonable in that
case
to question the existence of reality
i mean sabine i feel like i'm going to
get a blistering response to that but
well it depends on what you mean by a
reasonable you know if
if you're a philosopher and you make
your living with writing about that kind
of thing it's certainly reasonable to
think about it
but if the question is
is it useful
do we get anything out of it um i don't
see what
i i can't really see
you know um
if if you as i said it depends on what
you mean by computer simulation right uh
if you're comfortable just calling the
current north of nature computer
simulation and that's pretty much the
end of the discussion so we can leave it
with that
and uh when when you're asking about
what are the properties of those laws
that would have to go on that computer
um well
either you're doing
theoretical physics then you have to
take it seriously or you're not doing
science and you're not contributing to
anything that i find interesting so i
would say it's pretty much useless
philosophers take it i mean does anyone
in the panel want to step in defense of
the
questions no wait what
wait wait now i want to step in but not
in defense necessarily on the question i
think again sabine is right i don't know
about this philosophy thing as sabine
knows uh there are lots of scientists
who make a living out of things that are
highly questionable and not particularly
interesting um but
i mean to be fair right
but reasonable is in fact a good a good
question is it reasonable and it does
depend on what you mean by reason
so uh as you pointed out in the
introduction in fact uh this question is
not new doesn't come out of boston or or
anything like that at the very least it
goes back to the car
so was he reasonable and his exercise in
radical doubt basically he said you know
once at least in a lifetime you should
wake up and consider that maybe
everything you know it's not actually
true and ask yourself why the hell do i
think that uh this is true and that is
not true i mean that's a reasonable
exercise i think that's actually
something that once in a while we all
ought to to do
as a at least over breakfast or even
better
over a drink
but is it reasonable to spend a lot of
time money energy effort and all that
sort of stuff thinking about stuff that
does not make any contact as far as i
know with the empirical
then there the answer i think is no
yeah there might be a useful distinction
between
uh reasonableness and usefulness here i
think you're getting too as well that
you know science in general has done
rather well by just making that
supposition that there is an objective
reality that is to some extent mind
independent and let's let's try to
figure out what its properties are how
it works uh that seems to be a very
useful thing to do but also you know it
is useful to question the surface
appearance of things in my work as a as
a neuroscientist like you can go a long
way by questioning the the apparent
realism of things as they appear in our
perceptual experience like colors seem
to be part of a mind independent
objective reality but they aren't and
newton can tell us that i mean
you need a brain of a particular kind
for such a thing as color to exist so
there is mileage
in challenging
this this basic equation that that how
things seem as how they are and and the
way i perceive the world is how
objective reality really is but of
course that's the business of science
and especially physics to go underneath
the surface appearance of things and
figure out
what our best
predictive explanation of objective
reality is
and that of course can produce some
rather counterintuitive results after
all the best model we have of reality is
that we are literally have a handful of
quantum fields where
we we're all our particles are just
excitations and actually they're just
five fundamentally enormously big
complicated things interacting in some
kind of hilbert space that's worse than
the matrix in some sense it's even
weirder
and yet i think we would say
sabine of course can correct me on the
getting the physics really straight and
right but that picture is very different
and the surface reality we see is kind
of an unfolding of some deeper things
going on which are quite frankly very
very dissimilar from our normal
experience and indeed make a computer
simulation of earth run by some teenager
in his basement look downright normal
so i think there's something very
important about doing these mind
stretches and trying to figure out
reality but i think also there is
important question is it even a
dangerous idea to think that reality
isn't real
because in practice of course the real
question for practically any piece of
information you get is so what how
should i change my life given that i got
this piece of information
so as long as i'm not getting
information that i actually am in
assimilation i just have this weight
suspicion that maybe i could be
that doesn't seem to change anything i
should be doing
if i were suddenly told by a giant
pop-up window across the sky yes anders
you are in the simulation that might
still actually not change things very
much except if it says earned it will
shut down in five minutes in which case
of course i will immediately rush off to
the tent and get me some wine or
something
then i actually have my rush off to a
psychiatrist that might also be a
reasonable thing
right yeah and given kind of my
probabilities and credences maybe i
should probably first start with a quick
check in with the psychiatric did you
see that pop-up window up there yeah
okay let's have a bind together
that's interesting i mean we're i guess
it's jumping ahead a little bit but
there is i think there's an important
point there like what difference does it
make and you said you know in everyday
life if i'm going to have a glass of
water which is too far away then i can't
then it doesn't make any difference at
all right this is a very subtle way of
asking for it yeah i i
but there is a there is a way it might
make a difference and it's a sort of
more overarching way that you know the
world is basically on fire as we know
and if we have this high level belief
that it's it's a simulation and that
there may be many other simulations
running and that some you know
adolescent super gen you know far
distant teenager can just reset it and
start again we may run the risk of just
taking what's actually happening around
us a little less seriously and that has
actually been an important historical
thing not with the simulation argument
but thomas moynihan and his historian of
ideas wrote this definite work on
looking at existential risk and the idea
that we could go extinct as a species
and this would be a very bad thing is
surprisingly recent it only became kind
of thinkable in the 20th century and one
of the big reasons why people before
didn't take it very seriously it was
this idea that oh there's always going
to be people in other times in other
places of course we're going to be
people on jupiter and i can't famously
argue that god would not create planets
that wouldn't have any inhabitants
every there would be always a kind of a
backup everywhere and that actually
acted very much against the urgency we
feel like oh no we might be the only
planet with life in the intelligence mid
universe and we might not be handling it
very well that gives us a tremendous
responsibility if we think we're alone
but here hold on hold on so first of all
responsibility to whom
if we're the only ones uh out here in
the universe which i don't think but
let's say that for the sake of argument
we are
who are we responsible to once we're
gone that's it done so there's no we
might still be responsive to ourselves
and the preferences we have about the
future and what our ancestors want to do
but uh if i'm gone i'm not responsible
anymore while i'm alive i'm responsible
but after i'm gone that's it but i want
to question a couple of your assumptions
there first of all i don't think it's
true
that uh
we have started considering our own
extinction only recently
put in those terms yes
but you know christians have believed
for thousands of years that at some
point the world is going to end but they
believed it was a meaningful end not the
elder meaning well if it is if this is
really a simulation then it's some there
is some meaning right a guy's running a
simulation can start it over and so on
and support well that might depend very
much about the intentions of the people
making the simulation and even if it
turns out that they want yeah and even
if the meaning is that they want to test
then let's say the health care
allocation in the nhs we might say we
assimilate the people actually want to
enjoy life we want to have love and do
other things we might actually not care
about your meaning we care about our
meaning absolutely um but but you see
where i'm going there
people have raised the issue that the
whole notion of a simulation matrix etc
etc is essentially a secular religion
it's really not that different from
christian uh the christian belief but
where does that lead us
no way it's like a christian belief
[Laughter]
i mean i mean how do you feel about this
conversation
well
i i think it i
i think it's certainly true that it's
too it's very similar to a type of
religion and you you could ask it's
exactly the same question about uh
more standard religions like
christianity what difference does it
actually make but it does as a matter of
fact make a difference to a lot of
people so i have some sympathy for that
so as long as people understand it's
just to believe
um that's fine with me i get a problem
if they make statements about physics
and i think that's also an interesting
issue what should we even look for you
said earlier that well we see the
symmetries of physics doesn't fit with
assimilation i'd slightly disagree with
what you said there because for example
i seem to remember that you argued that
lawrence in variance means that okay we
don't have any voxels in the simulation
which is totally true but you can make a
simulation that has lorenz invariants so
you could always get around by saying
well maybe this we haven't seen a sign
of that kind of bug
but the problem and this is of course
where things move into conceptual
possibility it's always well it may be a
different kind of simulation it's very
annoying because you can never disprove
it which is of course while the ghost of
karl popper is kind of hovering around
here and say how do you falsify this
belief
yeah but look you just you just made a
big statement about
the laws of nature we can just make your
simulation out of florence invariant can
you actually do this on a computer that
proceeds in discrete time steps and
actually reproduce all the observations
that we have that's a pretty big claim
yeah but that one is something we can
get in front of a white board or a
computer and actually start
demonstrating or testing i mean that got
very nerdy very fast didn't it
i i wanted to actually
maybe this is just me but at this point
in the the conversation i'm starting to
wonder what is reality can we just touch
back on that because i feel like there
was there was a bit of a division
between the sort of you mentioned it
yourself as well this sort of objective
reality and almost like a maybe
perceived reality and there's sort of a
distinction between those things maybe
am i right to sort of
feel that yeah i think so i think so and
i think there is this uh so
i've previously building on the language
of others described perception as a kind
of controlled hallucination which is
often misunderstood as the claim that
there is no objective reality out there
it's all made up and of course the
control is equally as important as the
hallucination here what i'm trying to
emphasize there is that the way we
experience the world
is an internal construction generated by
our by our brains and bodies but it is
of course not independent of what's
actually out there otherwise we wouldn't
be doing a very good job of staying
alive evolution has designed our
perceptual systems to perceive things
in ways that are useful for our
continued existence that help us stay
alive basically and what we perceive
just again a very
basic example of color is both
less than and more than
whatever objective reality might be
described as as as a sort of mind
independent thing we know the
photoreceptors in our eyes are only
sensitive to three wavelengths out of
the whole electromagnetic spectrum
so it's less than but then we experience
a whole universe of colors so in that
sense it's it's more than that universe
of colors doesn't exist in the
electromagnetic spectrum only has a
potential when it's interacting uh with
something else so there is this i think
very important distinction in in asking
on the one hand and this is sort of more
the purview of neuroscience and
psychology what is the relationship
between
our perceptual experience and the causes
of that perceptual experience in the
world
and then more the purview of physics
how best to describe those causes at the
most fundamental level
yeah there is there is a long uh
tradition in philosophy of non-radical
skepticism there is the radical
skepticism right and it goes back even
way before the card heroes
back in ancient greece but at about the
same time as bureau there were
non-radical skeptics sometimes referred
to as academic skeptics because they
temporarily took over plato's academy
after plato died and the the
one of those was cicero who incidentally
invented the word probability he comes
from the latin probabilis and that's
that was exactly his point he was saying
look uh
reality is very likely out there uh
we don't know with how to access reality
directly we can only make probable
statements on the basis of our
understanding and perception and that's
really all we have we don't we don't
have direct access to reality whatever
that is so i don't know that there is
actually an answer to the question of
what reality is that's a very
interesting genealogy there because you
basically you know and then you go
through cancer as well and so basically
the claim now is that it's not only that
us as
as people with you know rational
thoughts
make statements of that sort that's
basically what the brain is doing in the
business of perception as well the brain
is figuring out the most probable
perceptual statements about objective
reality and that's what we experience
and we know that the brain can be wrong
or if i make up stuff right you know i i
don't have i have a blind spot i know
yeah because i can show to myself the
blind spot if i'm very careful but
normally i don't perceive it i run
around and it's like it's all continuous
my brain is making up stuff literally
perceptions that i'm that that are not
there i'm a little worried about that
because this idea of
being wrong and making up stuff and
filling in it sort of suggests there
would be a completely accurate way of
perceiving objective reality if only the
brain didn't have its but but that's not
the case it's like it's all a
construction there is no there is no
criterion of absolutely no that's right
verticality yeah no it's i think
the the claim is only that uh the brain
could be doing better like i could have
no blind spots uh there are animals that
don't have blind spots because as a
result of evolutionary reason we have
blind spots because evolution is a
quirky thing and at some point our our
blood vessels got twisted around our
nerves optical nerve got twisted around
and attached in a particular way
octopuses don't have that so they don't
have blind spots so it could be done
better that doesn't mean that they have
access to reality as it is
that's interesting i mean what i'm
hearing i'm a scientist actually i
should have
like declared my uh affiliation at the
start of this not a philosopher but i'm
not a philosopher no but what i heard
and what you were saying actually was
um
you know we aren't able to access
reality directly but we have generated a
methodology that we call science
which we use to to sort of
gauge that reality
would that be fair to say do we think
she's going to get out scientists by the
other scientists on the panel
well i think it's it's very unlikely
that we're going to answer the question
what is reality
in the limited amount of time that we
have
i i think for for what scientists
working scientists are concerned
it's just a useful construct
that that we apply to our theories and i
mean it's certainly an agreement with
what we observe that uh a lot of
what we observe doesn't really care a
lot about us right and and i i think
that that's the reason why we
find it useful to think of an external
reality that exists independent of us
does it mean that it actually exists
well
we can never be quite sure right
i mean that leads me on to my third and
final question which is are we just
victims to hollywood fantasy
anyone want to does anyone want to jump
in with that for me it's funny that this
this is called lost in the matrix
because the matrix is actually not like
the simulation hypothesis at all right
so the the whole premise of the matrix
and i'm hoping the fourth instantiation
of it is non-shit i mean
that is a bold statement
um you know the premise of the matrix is
there are real brains that are in some
some sort of factory farm environment
being being milked for their for their
power and really the experience that
people like neo and all the characters
in the matrix have is due it's more the
brain in the vat experiment that their
brain activity has been manipulated in
particular ways so that they have this
experience of the real
world that's a very very different claim
to the fact to the claim that the
universe is in fact a computer
simulation and we are all characters
within that computer simulation i love
the first movie but it's a really
horrible premise
human human brains generate so little
power that these robots are just crazy
if they if they think they can run
things off of human brain but whatever
yeah that's true
there are other movies that are getting
closer to this like 13th floor which
i think is decent but
we didn't have that visual appeal etc
and i found it interesting because
stories that your reality isn't real
they are relatively recent certainly
there are a lot of stories where people
are recounting things that turn out to
be dreams which is a good way for the
author to say that okay i'm not actually
not claiming that i actually went to the
moon or that these things happen
but then gradually you get to alice in
wonderland where it's actually being
played around with of course
the author was a logician and was kind
of happy to do recursive stories stories
within stores playing around with the
weird metaphysical possibilities that
happen if you happen to be a dream about
being inside a chess game etc
and gradually we are matured i think
when it comes to storytelling we have
actually learned to accept that stories
within stories or simulated worlds are
part of the paraphernalia we might use
in
our thinking and i think that is in
itself an interesting part because we
use these kind of images of the future
images of possibilities to reason about
other things when bringing up the risks
of artificial intelligence typically all
of us on the invertebrate groan whenever
somebody brings up the terminator but
it's a standard picture
slowly being nudged out by uh
ava from x marking unfortunately but
it's still kind of these standard
pictures we use for good and ill and i
think
the ability to think that well what if
this was like the matrix or 13th floor
is a useful way of reasoning about many
other things because i do think the
matrix movies got something right many
people feel a weird sense of unreality
there is this unrequited love from the
vachovsky's uh to baudrillard
and
many of us probably feel that when we're
spending our days kind of going through
social media where half of our twitter
followers are probably bots in some form
pretending to be humans for various
nefarious political purposes
speak for yourself anders
well i would say the the
maybe the notion of stories in the way
we now are talking about it is recent
but again
the use of made-up scenarios and you
know interesting stories to make a point
an important part or you know a
philosophical or a scientific point it's
actually very old again at the very
least it goes back to plato i mean his
image of the cave for instance this one
uh he made up a bunch of myths like
atlantis i'm sorry if you didn't know
that atlantis is a myth uh spoiler alert
uh
right so and and you so it's
storytelling is important so i don't
think we're necessarily victims of
hollywood except in the fact that
typically hollywood stories are bad
badly written and not particularly
interesting but the matrix wasn't an
exception the first one precisely
because it was well thought out
almost and and well and well written um
i also wanted to add one more thing the
fact that elon musk supports the idea
it's a good reason not to believe it
but elon actually has a reasonable
reason to think it
imagine waking up and realizing wait a
minute i'm a billionaire with a space
program and stuff like that what's the
likelihood that i'm not in a computer
game i'm sorry
i don't know musk personally but i
follow him on twitter and unless he's a
bot that psychological description does
not even begin to actually match
with the reality i think he knows
perfectly well why he's a billionaire
fascinating stuff
i mean
yeah i think i think you do raise a
really interesting point actually about
the role of sort of
storytelling literature in modern day
times obviously film increasingly um in
in sort of thought experiment basically
isn't it that's what it is it's somebody
thinking being told a sort of scientific
fact or a possibility or a theory and
then creating an art piece basically to
engage with that and but but wait part
experiments great so
thought experiments are very important
both in philosophy and in science but
they become relative relevant when they
actually touch on the empirical right so
we have famous fat experiments in
science einstein imagining that it was
you know on on a light wave galileo
dropping stuff from the tower pisa which
you never actually did
that sort of stuff but the reason those
are important is because at some point
they they made contact with with reality
with the empirical people could actually
use those thought experiments to do real
experiments and to advance our knowledge
of the world such such as it is this one
doesn't strike me as one of those but it
does touch on the consistency of our
beliefs basically that trilemma or that
quadrilema shows that there is something
wrong here something in the reasoning
that led us up to this situation is
really wonky and that is useful to know
then we might say okay i totally believe
that that one is not plausible at all
or
this tension we can investigate that
we can get in front of a whiteboard and
try to see if we i can make a
model that shows the right kind of local
symmetries we can get over to the
questions about wait a minute
credibility and plausibility and
possibility here maybe that is actually
breaking the argument but
it notice that these things are internal
in some sense to the philosophical thing
it doesn't tell us that much about
whether this reality is actually
simulated for that we need to look for
pop-up windows or some weird buggy and
physics i mean that leads me into the
burning question that i have i don't
know about any of you right now but like
what would it take to prove that like
how are we going to prove if we are or
aren't in a simulation
well proof is a very high standard i
think it's better to math
you know we can't really prove a lot but
having empirical evidence of something
that that might be that might be a good
starting point and i mean in that case
the burden of truth is for evidence it's
squarely on his shoulders
here is an interesting possibility that
a friend of mine suggested suppose we go
out into space and finally meet the
aliens and they turn out to be a real
advanced super civilization and they
they are running zillions and zillions
of ancestor simulations of their own
ancestors in order to find out some
weird alien questions about history
that seems to be the kind of evidence
that would change our plausibilities a
bit because we know at least that looks
like there for some reason are able to
do then maybe we are assimilated you
want to try getting a grant for that
yes first we need a space especially a
five year grant yeah
yeah yeah
very happy to do it
well i think i think it's i mean it's
it's i think it is a little
it's a little much to ask of it to come
up with proof or evidence it doesn't
seem the kind of thing that evidence can
bear on in a useful way at least in the
near-term horizon i do think the value
of it in as much as there is
is in just probing some of the natural
sort of rivers of thinking that we tend
to apply ultimately i i i still think
there's great reason to be skeptical of
both the argument so we should
distinguish as well the argument which
is this trilemma or quadrilemma from the
hypothesis that this is actually the
case
and even i think boston you will know
better is is uncommitted to the
hypothesis but committed to the
arguments
it is useful in how it changes
assumptions we might otherwise
make and actually i've when i was
thinking about this just now so one of
the the reasons i'm i'm suspicious of it
is this assumption that
consciousness is substrate independent
right so you could actually turn it the
other way around this is probably really
bad philosophy but you could turn the
other way around and say okay this is
actually a very the simulation argument
is a very good argument against
functionalism because um
if functionalism is true then the
simulation argument might follow and
that seems bonkers so let's not do that
but that's that's not good but i do
think it's useful how it changes the way
we think i like it i i don't think
bonkers doesn't necessarily mean that
the argument is wrong
but it's interesting you mentioned that
uh bostrom is committed to the argument
but not to the hypothesis right that
strikes me suspicious
right i mean if i think that an argument
is really good then i'm committed well
no the argument is that there are these
three well he three and i think now four
possibilities the fourth possibility
being that consciousness is not
substrate independent right and the
argument is simply that one of those
things has to apply
so for example he's very committed to
trying to reduce existential risk
because
if you agree with argument that seems
that you need maybe to assign more
probability than you normally would to
the possibility that we might be doomed
and maybe we should do something about
that so you can take the other horn and
say oh we really really need to reduce
nukes
but that's bizarre if i were really
convinced that that all i am the reality
is a computer simulation probably run by
a kid uh who doesn't have anything else
to do uh in the afternoon why would i
care about my existential risk yeah but
that is when obviously one of the other
horns of a trilemma you can also say
that the first horn is it's very likely
that we are going to be in trouble and
never simulate
the past
so in that case you know the urgency of
fixing existing risk goes up
or you might end up with the second one
oh future post posthumous are going to
be really well coordinated immoral
that's a really old foot how how would
they ever get up there
have we decided that we are or we aren't
i mean where are we i don't know
we don't know i'm waiting for the pop-up
window
i'm yeah i mean i think we might be
waiting a while right before something
that obvious turns up yeah i just think
there's there's very little credence to
assign to that
that belief and so in a sense it doesn't
much matter whether the argument stands
as an argument it's just very very
unlikely on that note i'm really sorry
everybody i have to thank the speakers
if you'd like to join your hands and
clapping forward wonderful speakers
podcasts talks debates courses and
articles
visit the institute of